what is up there reject nation thank you
so much for coming here to check us out
with squid game episode three the man
with the umbrella been really enjoying
this show so far please comment please
comment and hit that like button while
you're at it but yeah we're also like
don't read too many comments
make sure to subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next quick game reaction is up thank
you to all who have subscribed so far of
course full length watch along recycle
but the time code is over at our patreon
page cover a whole bunch of shows over
there where we have both the option for
reaction highlights and watch long
included thank you to the team at pray
for for uh editing down these highlights
for us buddy
let's do it
[Music]
come on go undercover man go undercover
they must have a deal with that car i
think you can make it actually easier to
detect who you are with
everyone having the same thing yeah
it's gonna say who's sponsoring this
operation
oh my oh dude he's cape fearing this
dude
how terrible would it be if he drove
forward and there's just a smear of
blood
nice
kill him
dude
you should have definitely messaged your
police station saying that you think
this game is real yeah or whatever
a little more of a heads up i think
you've got at least enough proof to
prove something nefarious is happening
it's good that you reminded him of said
rule yeah you circle battle of the
squares and triangles
[Music]
oh you're on the team i do
absolutely on the team
you
i think she probably meant
a lot broader things than that
[Music]
i also wonder if he has like some dark
secret or something she's just too good
[Music]
man the tension of any time something
seems
someone slightly doesn't know they're
routine it's suspicious
they gotta be victims too or something
that would frustrate me too
oh this dude can never take off his mask
stop looking suspiciously at the camera
oh man
[Music]
you guys should probably keep it down
when you're in the vents
[Music]
it's like the iron giant
what's going on they're baking evil
cookies
[Music]
[Laughter]
body language
i hate my job i feel so embarrassed
i have no one to talk to about this
there's no hr
stop whispering about [ __ ] guys they
probably can hear you
they're probably listening to everything
everywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what has he found
oh
[Laughter]
hmm okay
[Music]
i have that tough mudder i could handle
this
yeah what more is a few extra guns
this looks a lot more intricate
oh no it's like an actual
obstacle course yeah it's like a
playground
oh
is
[Music]
yeah maybe maybe somebody upstairs likes
them
[Music]
dang there's even a close-up on an
umbrella like a
first episode that's right
is he holding out on them
i don't he seems preoccupied with
someone
[Music]
buy my mixtape
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh i see why you chose triangle my guy
oh my god oh dude
i would beat sophie screw too man
they really know when to drop everything
out and just go with the silence to
raise the tension
like just the diegetic sound effects
oh no
no please be the cop
oh oh oh
we killed the beginning we sacrifice him
do
first guy to die was on the slide yeah
spent his last moments on the best part
of the playground
oh
it'll be all the time too yeah
oh no
[Laughter]
this is so brutal
is she smoking a cigarette i think she's
yellow
[Laughter]
oh clever did she get in trouble for
that i don't know i mean it looked like
that one guy was watching her but
guys gotta work with these dead bodies
already i know
i'm trying to keep count of how many
gunshots
oh well done my guy
just like you
tell
come on man
all right anybody with him
you can even kill the main character
old man kill anybody you want
[Laughter]
we'll touch ollie
how's that umbrella coming along
he's going to be down in the water man
dude i would mess this up i can't even
carve a pumpkin
as simple as shapes that'll be game
number three oh
no
i'm going to write you up
quincy
ah
so they're helping him out i guess
[Music]
why don't you tell him dude
oh
wait wait can i work to his advantage
yeah you can use that you can soften
awesome
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
use of physics my dude
don't overlook it
[Music]
oh
beautiful job beautiful i've just carved
it
hey
[Laughter]
like a boss
oh no oh
[Music]
he could so easily be caught though i
know
[Music]
so he's just gonna look it up
are you gonna do any carving man
[Music]
[Laughter]
everyone following his steps
[Music]
i love this twisted humor
yeah man you gotta find childlike
solutions to these childlike games
what the hell did he gotta do
game hacks
oh wait no that's a gangster guy
i could lose
[Music]
she's got it you got it
come on man
you've done all the licking come on
moment of truth
[Music]
on that one
[Music]
dude his buddy totally tried to dick him
over yeah
oh you're so close
whoa
ouch
[Music]
whoa
oh but he's a square he's important
[Applause]
wow he came down to do that
yeah
[Music]
those coffins
with bows on them
switch masks
nice
wow
you know what's interesting about this
one in particular
is the first one with red light green
light they have this whole crazy
mechanical
thing set up in place
this sensor detector
thingamajig
it's almost like
science fiction-esque right
with like i mean like i feel like that's
a there's a way to invent something like
that where you know like the guns come
out protrude and start shooting people
like based off motion detecting
and then this one was just no they're
gonna play the actual just the real game
and then the guards here or whatever
they are i have no idea what what they
really are but whoever they are the the
the many henchmen the game enforcers
yeah yeah
they they just shoot you in the end you
know like they just actually played the
real
game i don't know what the game is i've
never played it before i don't know if
i'm assuming it's a real one um
but like this felt more unnerving
due to the fact that they are just
playing like a what feels like a real
kids game yeah you know they don't have
any of these crazy mechanical
contraptions around here uh that are
kind of thrusting you into something
that's like what is this weird ass you
know this is just like a playground they
set up they're just playing with this so
there's something that feels more
unsettling to me
uh in the fact that this is just adults
playing a kid's game and then they're
just going to be gunned down if they
don't actually succeed in doing it yeah
because yeah i think there is an
interesting contrast there because two
it's like you have them in a playground
setting where all the fixtures are much
bigger than they are so it's even more
down that alleyway of yeah you're just
doing this demented kid activity on the
same scope and scale the kids would do
it except yeah now it's even closer down
to earth because it's yeah it's like
having the big you know animatronic girl
thing it makes it feel more sci-fi
even though what ultimately happens that
they are just being shot but yeah
there's something so much uh it's i
don't know they're both bleak and stark
but yeah having just these executioners
essentially standing all around to just
take everybody out one by one is is
really menacing and i love the way that
they use that to heighten the tension
especially with like the gangster guy
with the tattoo because like so much
you're watching everybody else you know
kind of figure it out or panic and you
can tell in a more sort of released kind
of way that just like the progression of
this game is wearing down
his ability to kind of stay tough in
this paradigm yeah and yeah well the way
they they compose all their shots here
they have an interesting scope with how
they do it all
like from beginning to end there's
there's something i don't know what that
that i'm trying to figure out what the
word is for that type of
weird like
because you like how you brought up the
objects there's something that they do
with it it's not in every shot but a lot
of the shots even when they're not in
the playground there's almost this like
magnified quality in some of like the
foreground of the shots here's a really
crazy depth of field thing yeah
something like that yeah and it's it
really is weird to me like this it's
weird uncomfortable
but i i gotta admit it's also like very
entertaining like this whole show is
extremely entertaining you can feel
like this grasp on rhythm here you know
we're three episodes in
and i'm already feeling like it's it's
shaping up like each one is an act of a
movie
more so than it is
uh like a a series maybe that vibe will
change but this is feeling like acts of
a movie yeah we are
in like the midpoint or i mean how many
episodes are there nine nine yeah
close to middle school
a little bit before midpoint yeah we
might have just reached midpoint or
something like it seems like each
episode is taking an act of a film and
just making that an hour or like like
okay the first episode was like act one
like the first two were like sort of
like an act one you know yeah it's the
debate of like ultimately going into
this yeah
real yeah and really committing to it
and it's that this one adapted more of
uh of a ironic dark humor about it yeah
you know like it it helps i wouldn't say
it's like alleviates tension it's just
there's something kind of odd about when
they're all back here i like how
they all return here but there's a sense
of familiarity amongst them because it
is familiar
and it's not
uh just them being stoic instead you've
it it's a weird thing of how like
they're all strangers and then they come
back here and there's camaraderie they
all have a lot now because of this
incredibly unique circumstance they've
only now come back to yeah yeah with
only like a handful of them missing it
is it is funny to me how they seem to
just have like
i mean i imagine some of these things
and whatever the history is of this
like
game cult thingy and i'm wondering too
if there's americans involved because
because i i'm remembering now the first
guy dr doom he
he spoke in english in the first episode
so i was like okay is there like
american [ __ ] happening in here
broadcasting
i was wondering too is is he like the
liaison for like the the top owners of
debt in the world because like you know
everybody it seems like on their game
list is in incredible amounts of debt
and they even said monitor the people
who didn't come back so i wonder if i
don't know there's some kind of
huge you know shadowy illuminati pyramid
of just you know who pulls the strings
of finance across the world there could
be some american element to that well
there has to be i mean this is it's
obviously riffing on classism in in the
way how
uh
you know like
capitalism can
the greedy side of it all can i mean i'm
sure there's more specifically linked
towards like korea you know that i that
i am too i'm too dumb to talk about
economics
enough to the ignorance to speak about
it however you know it's like this the
the kind of like looking upon us like
ants those who because they treat them
like animals here yeah and
but i'm really enjoying i'm really
enjoying it like some of the cat that
that one woman is is very frustrating
not not the cool young chick with the
knife oh the the woman with the
cigarettes yeah yeah she's very
frustrating um
and i don't find anything like a pool
about her
but it's not to say i'm not enjoying
when whatever the plot is doing with her
like yeah i'm always i'm i'm buckled in
ready to go on this this ride you're
going like all right what's what's gonna
progress with her i wanna see that like
like she can be off i don't care if she
dies uh gangster guy can be off but i
don't know maybe they're gonna do
something down the road i end up liking
them
they're going to find true romance yeah
yeah but then they but they're also
setting up that there is a bigger
mystery happening here the one guy who
seemed he seemed like he was on the
lookout for that note in the bread like
he intentionally was like
he wasn't like huh like it seemed like
he was aware that there's going to be
something here for him and that they
even guide him to the left so i don't
know what he is or who he is and i'm not
really going to spend so much time
trying to figure it out either yeah you
know and then we got the cop guy who and
i love the way they play with that
because everything here is so militant
to the point where if something is
slightly off just as something simple as
the turn of the key the wrong way it's
like wait you should know that that
should be like a subconscious thing yeah
your muscle memory yeah so i love having
like the suspicion rise upon him
over something as minor as that yeah
like it's good it's good attention to
detail when this whole world is all
about detail yeah you know and so uh
like you have that plot line going and
uh i i love this like affable quality to
our main guy this uh
incred it's it's weird like you
introduce this him into the show and and
it's in some ways he's like perfectly
suited for this game for these games
because you know he's a grown-ass man
but he's very much a child at the same
time like he can't take care of himself
he's not independent uh he still lives
with his mom and uh like he has all
these responsibilities that but
everything he does it's kind of like a
child you know like he does he he lacks
adult maturity
and so like even resorting to like the
desperation of the umbrella cookie or
whatever that is like licking it like
it's a very like you have to use your
imagination like a kid and just go with
it so there is this
like any and he doesn't seem to pick up
on like social cues from people around
him
so it's neat how they've
drawn that with him because of like well
because you're kind of like a kid dude
you might be like the
yeah
perfect
yeah so um the damn his friend [ __ ]
him over his friend totally knew what
the game was yeah he held back there he
totally held back and he was willing to
sacrifice him he was supposed to be a
team man well and see that's i mean
probably thinks he's inferior and would
hold him back
yeah well and he know like you know at
that point
you've got you know the star in the
triangle it's uh yeah he's not gonna
give up the he's not for himself gonna
give up the best piece and at that point
if he says anything it's gonna cause way
too much trouble so it's like i i wonder
i really wonder what's going to become
of that character and if there will be a
confrontation about that i mean i'm sure
that
thread of of him will you know continue
but yeah like i really like the way that
they lace those moments in because it is
very sort of natural but you also know
something's there and it adds to this
tension and i think that's one of the
best assets of the show across the board
is like their tension and like you said
the pacing and the way that they
juxtapose those things over time because
the other thing is like for netflix
shows you know i often associate these
with you know high binge ability and not
that this show doesn't leave me at the
second of every ending wanting to
immediately continue but these episodes
feel really they don't feel cliffhanger
dependent no they feel really well
proportioned and it also feels like
you're spending
it feels like you're spending a lot more
time here like you know even this second
episode it takes a good amount of time
to get to the game and you do a whole
lot of stuff in the world just of
what it's like to be these contestants
onboarding and then peering into the
lives of the people who are you know
orchestrating everything and it really
lives in all of that in a way that helps
to ramp the tension and two just the way
that they know how to drop the music out
and really rely on the sounds in the
room to make you crazy is so good well
the music itself reflects tension yeah
it's almost like playing on a heartbeat
in a way yeah absolutely it's all very
rhythmic and percussive and tension
heavy
all right guys well episode three thank
you so much for being here but
appreciate you go ahead and hit that
like button if you end up enjoying our
video subscribe and click that bell
check us out on patreon we'll catch you
guys soon